So, we've got the target and the bridge and the water command comes off the,
the target command by just moving the target into the water. I can also ask
Callie to go target at a distance from me, that's something I call a remote
target. And it works just like my hand target does. Callie. Target. Hold. Where
Callie will touch her nose to that spot. And part of the shaping of that
behavior, good. Is that we extend the target behavior out for longer and longer
durations of time as Callie has had a chance to master the behavior. Good. Now,
we can add, to create more complicated behaviors, we can add more target points
onto the animal's body. So, this is the flipper target, and I can use this
flipper target to examine Callie's flippers and her under surface to make sure
that there's no cuts or abrasions, or anything developing that we wouldn't
want to see. Good. We can create a target on any place of the animal's body
that we want. Good. And we have created even more complicated targets. Callie
has a head target. Head.
[LAUGH]
Good. That I've used to create other behaviors such as this one for example,
which is called flexible. Good. So, this is the head target that I use and I
moved closer and closer back. Good! To create this behavior which is now on
cue. Okay, this is a new behavior for Callie, she's just learning this
behavior, and because of that, the target pole prop is still in there. Some of
these other behaviors no longer has the target that used to create the
behavior. So, just like my hand target, the target pole. The end of the target
pole is where Callie is going to put her nose. Wherever I put my target, Callie
will put her nose. And with some practice and practicing the antecedent of the
cue, or the command, prior to the behavioral sequence that I'm forming through
operand conditioning. I can eventually take the target pullout and she will do
the behavior just on command because of the rehearsal history. In this case,
the behavior is not ready for the target pull to be removed yet .This is the
back flip behavior for, which my program is famous. That is our logo. And this
behavior is initially formed in the lower portions of the water, where the
animal has full control. And they learn to first do the back flip here. Good.
Then I use the target pole to lift the back flip up and hold it in position out
of the air like so after being preceded by the antecedent cue. Flip, good,
flip! Flip, good! And that's how you get a back flip. Good job. Way to go you!
Yeah! Good job!
[NOISE]
Good. The benefits of animal training and husbandry, demonstrated live and in
person by Callie the sea lion.